going back to when you did the
fundraiser what were some of the first
steps to organize it what were some of
the things that you have food music like
what what did it entail well the Playboy
Mansion took care of all the food they
took care of the whole party aspect of
it we provided the film and they gave us
mailing lists and we collecting mailing
lists was the biggest job and we
collected the mailing lists and send out
invitations not responses and went and
had a great party so to another
filmmaker who wants to fundraise you
first need to find a venue probably and
then see if you could get any kind of
donated entertainment food drinks things
like that yeah I we didn't really want
to have any entertainment because the
film is this actually actually the
centerpiece so we had a wonderful buffet
afterwards and a friend of ours Kimberly
Bailey baked us the most gorgeous girls
in the band cake which was a picture of
our logo and you know that was sort of
the centerpiece of the end of the party
but it was really just we were there for
the film and there was a Q&A afterwards
and you know people stuck around and
talked pick talking took photos and
that's what the event was would you
advise that people send out invitations
through regular US mail or email no we
sent out I think we sent out a you know
kind of a paperless post invitation with
it I think no I'm sorry I'm sorry for
that we did send out mail we send out
mail invitations and we had cards
printed up that people rsvp'd on and
sent out envelopes like you were being
invited to something really fancy yeah
we did do that for that we've sent every
kind of invitation at every kind of
email imaginable it's been a real
learning curve on how to get people to
your screenings and how to do that kind
of stuff do you think the art of fun
for films is a loss is a little bit of a
lost art now that crop bunnies around
what do you think it's still coexist but
it seems like now I don't turn to
crowdfunding which again is wonderful
but i'm just wondering with the
fundraising I don't know I really don't
know how other people are fundraising I
think I think the filmmakers that I know
are all doing the same thing that I did
they're all beating down the doors
because you have to go to places for
grants you have to go to foundations you
have to go to the neh and the NEA and
you know those things all take a lot of
a lot of intensive work
you